ma fille diane appelé pour me dire
qu'elle n'a pas le temps de m'appeler
bah c'est gentil mais je t'appelle
regarde
non mais j'aurais où elle accomplit les
jours aujourd'hui elle a fait ça
à bon bah oui qui veux-tu que ce soit au
la merde j'ai dû faire une fausse manip
magnifique chrono elle nos enfants c'est
pas sûr qu'il soit là
commence à faire sérieusement chez ces
deux petits quand nos enfants de nos
calculs plus on va les faire nos calculs
et allez c'est parti coucou chéri on a
gagné avec papa beaucoup d'argent à tous
bisous bisous
pour bien oui elle est combien
18 quoique mais gare à maman
il faut consacrer 10 rue 89 le rouler 20
minutes il m'a porté
c'est bon j'ai déjà marchand et moi je
veux mettre en vol
ont leur manque je voudrais rhabiller ma
fille pour l'isère
la chute qui a ils sont par mon porte
monnaie mais non elle aux enfants sont
là pour le réveillon
c'était fou je viens de faire une tache
sur ma chemise comment je fais
[Musique]
tu as une paire de ciseaux qui découpe
autant de la tâche et normalement il
devrait plus avoir de tâches
[Musique]
m
non
c'est
la somme allouée
[Musique]
à l'omc de réguler
angers est des muscles possible
ces deux points
allez non
non
[Musique]
vous allez découvrir une famille
monstrueux ça va être en retard au
mariage arrive dans deux minutes
[Musique]
c'est une famille qui mène une existence
normale
baba yaga acceptez-vous
toit
[Musique]
pour les sauver nous devons nous
transforme et là ça sera sans moi on a
besoin d'eux le pouvoir
non mais c'est une blague descola plutôt
triste
[Musique]
monster family en route pour l'aventuré
tu vas rire à l'école on dit que notre
famille
sembla préparez vous à passer un noël de
folie avec darracq la baba yaga mais si
le dating mais aussi king kong bref vous
allez prendre une sacrée claque
monster family en route pour l'aventuré
cash décembre au cinéma rien
moi si je pouvais aller coller mes
fesses sur une île déserte je
n'hésiterai pas une seconde qu'ils
veulent remplir soi-même des verts s'est
pas heureux
[Musique]
n'envoyez handicapés dans le fossé
j'arrive vous fait quoi bien l'avis
général quand je le dis ça jette un
froid
j'ai besoin de dieu pour cette offre
nous y tenons
[Musique]
qu'est ce que vous foutez la
visite je vous larguer comme ça en
pleine nature mais j'appelle problème
tout va bien sûr je rangerai plus
[Musique]
il lui faudra autre chose
je sais pas
[Musique]
samedi 26 à dormir à monteils commis
frey canton
[Musique]
on est tous
un barque qui
on sait pas où on va
on ignore tout la destination mais on
est à bord
c'est au stade dans c'est mon ami - au
regard d'autrui jona
moi je trouve que tu as l'air
normal ça se voit pas
bright
[Musique]
oh
tu n'hésitais de début à moi aussi je
suis auto bras j'ai mis toutes ses
affaires soient lus ni tabou parce que
ça non l'équité tu sais les secours et
reviens
nous est pas un stylo et du papier
[Musique]
je connais tellement
français
[Musique]
je veux en ligne de votre main est très
fatigué oui ça va mal dans votre tête ah
bah je vous dérange pas trop
je vous le monde
mais vous avez trouvé ça bien je vous
écris jd jeu non mais je sais pas ça me
sort de partout bien plus lui m pourquoi
je voudrais savoir le sud ça donne envie
jeune femme du troisième en face quand
on vous lit où la voix
ça a commencé quand
[Musique]
début je l'aimé comme un fou alors sa
peau on dit ça sans faire georges était
la complicité virile
là je peux pas
encore un an quand vous décrochez pas
c'est quoi ça j'ai rien d'une porte ou
presque c'est très bien tout ça c'est
pâques à cause d'elle c'est vrai que un
peu jeune pour vous mais qu'est ce que
ça veut dire elle est un peu jeune
[Musique]
excusez moi je me sens pas très bien
peut-être car dix
autres l'élu de b crois qu'il faut pas
e
[Applaudissements]
tél
mettons d'abord les choses au croire
qu'il s'agit d'un journal de bord pas
d'un journal intime demain c'est mon
premier jour au collège heureusement je
suis pas tout seul au collège il ya mon
meilleur ami robert
voilà ce que tu dois savoir fais
attention tu t'assois le premier jour
n'utilisent jamais les toilettes du
deuxième étage surtout fait attention de
ne pas attraper la marque du fromage
parce que sinon c'est comme si tu étais
mort
merci beaucoup rodrigues pour ces
merveilleux concert
tout va bien se passer au collège je
vais demander à faire l'école à la
maison
on y pense heureusement chez moi tout
[Musique]
je pense qu'un passage aurait besoin
d'une bonne thérapie
on est au collège maintenant tu crois
pas pour devrait se comporter comme des
garçons de notre âge
tu veux voir
beauté secrète mais cette forêt m'a
traumatisé pour toujours
regardez moi ces petits clowns ils
traînent dehors au lieu de dormir
[Musique]
vachon maman un jour je serai riche et
célèbre mais pour l'instant je suis
coincé au collège entourée d'idiots
tant que tu restes avec moi tout ira
bien pour toi
[Musique]
ô êtes désolé j'avais pas vu que c'était
vous les garçons vous allez bien vous
allez bien
[Musique]
[ __ ] les [ __ ] m'ont volé ma
batterie kona un type vous en vendre une
mais c'est sûr c'est lui qui vous la
voler
enfin tel quel de mettre au frais avant
l'es3 avec l'oseille de l'outil business
à la con j'ai conservé tous les autres
sentheim
sentais pas bien du tout et c'est un
interrogatoire tu veux venir chanter
avec nous
[ __ ] mais jules
[Musique]
je l'étais quoi le commissaire a vécu
pire et a misé entre aussi le premier
qui m'ont jean-paul pour deux mois de
plus chez toi post war
ton frère et part en couille il me fait
le coup d'aller faire du chant genre
mariah carey
bon je te présente l'affiché les
approches ont été
frappés avant d'entrer au jeu par un cul
l'ars terminé balance ah non moi pas
mourir et va mourir ici
[Musique]
c'est ce que je lis mans pour venir
votre [ __ ] de contenir comment tu mens
pas
[Musique]
walfisz voilà il a du talent on sait pas
où ça me mènera mais maintenant il a le
champ pour lui un oiseau la traviata ça
peut l'aider à tout regarder
différemment lui donner de la joie de la
force
c'est comme ça c'est en lui ça va mais
il faut pas qu'ils passent à côté de
cette puissance folle
[Musique]
évidemment jamais
même pas voler
le célibat
le monde
une nouvelle mission de m
soyons des paris
[Musique]
un autre aurait rédigé une note à la
démission
[Musique]